if you help me okay so that's one we saw
another one earlier uh and not all of
them have the blue face
blue face
like the Creed
I mean it's a sin to cover any part of
Jonathan major's face right like this
guy he expresses with all 147 muscles of
a smile he can he can isolate them and
move them in specific I'm giving this
guy a lot of credit and he's beautiful
and it's okay you're just check it out
you just want to check out his face man
I don't blame you it's a handsome man I
mean right is it is it um is it
Shameless of me to say I just want to do
a breakdown of Jonathan major's face and
every second of screen time he's been on
just you know for the acting for science
for academic reasons purely that's it
yeah as long as it's not for looks
because that's for me I was gonna ask
you if I could but go for it
if it's a sexualizing Jonathan Majors
breakdown I'm the only one allowed to do
it but you guys can do his acting Parts
it's true contract welcome back to New
rockstars how many kings will be in
Quantum media is it just one of them are
there variants all warring against each
other in the quantum realm is it one
gang looking for excuses to run off to
the bathroom for a few minutes until he
who looks like an old English Nanny runs
back past does cursing welcome back to
the King game
this
is
it Jessica
I was drinking my smoothing you don't
want to be part of the Kang gang Jess
wow no I do the Smoothie comes first and
then King gang get a second okay yeah
okay smoothie then cake okay all right I
see it over the price you guys couldn't
hear it but the sloshing of the Smoothie
inside the cup made the sound of car
guards I got my Starbucks so I'm not as
fancy
this is the inside Marvel new rock stars
weekly Marvel reaction show I'm Eric
Voss with me today is Mt and Jessica
Clement Hello friends hi Eric I am ready
for the king Wars I am ready to see Kang
slap another Cane slap another king it
needs to happen uh just like a a Kang
chain reaction of just slaps going
it's the gang bang of Prophecy it's it's
gonna come the great gang bang we're in
an interesting spot this week on inside
Marvel everybody watching uh Jess and I
have had the luxury of seeing uh Black
Panther we're kind of forever but Mt Mt
is taking the true fan approach and seen
it opening night so we don't want to
spoil anything for him tonight we don't
spoil anything for any of you we're not
gonna be talking about what kind of
forever yet we'll talk about it all next
week once everyone's seen it and then
we'll all touch base then uh but today
there's just so many questions we still
have from quantumania
um and at the top of that list is how
many kangs are in this movie now I want
to ask both of you just from the get-go
when he first watched his trailer was
your initial gut reaction to this
initial impression was that we're seeing
one Kang or multiple kanks I thought we
were seeing one but then Brandon on the
break room was like I think it's
multiple so I had me second guessing
myself but I still think and I'm
planting my foot that it's one that it
is just one now starting now starting
now starting now what about you empty I
I definitely feel like we're gonna see
more than one king because like the Loki
finale sort of like sort of teed us up
for multiple Kings and like sort of that
expectation is there so I think that
largely in the movie we're probably
gonna deal with this main gang but like
maybe like he wants Scott to steal from
another Kang because they are in a war
um or we can see maybe this king is like
Hey we're all going to war with each
other but like this is like the starting
point so like they're he's like starting
an army of King it's like we're gonna
start to kill each other but this is the
starting point so like that Army shot we
see in the trailer maybe it's like all
right on your bars get set go
only one of us could win
enough the wild and crazy kids uh
episodes where all the different teams
all scramble and run past each other run
at the camera and is that a different
generation I'm sorry is that old man
boss uh hobbling in here being back in
the 90s we had Nickelodeon shows called
wild and crazy kids I was going towards
Rat Race oh yeah which is
I love rat race this is a good movie
that's a great it was a fun movie so
yeah my assumption has been that there
is only one Kang in this movie and in
some shots he has no headgear other
times he is wearing that helmet that
extends the blue face shield over his
face to protect himself similar to that
Tech that the Guardians of the Galaxy
use you know that faint blue translucent
layer that goes over the face and the
whole body to keep them oxygenated and
pressurized whenever they're in space
not yondu not yondu yeah yondu gave that
to Peter Quill and will never
gotta have a backup he looked at the the
backup on his way out and said I don't
need it
back
um and you know if they are doing this
for Kang like if normally he's going to
look like Jonathan Majors with the scars
but then just like extends a helmet over
his face I just like the city of using
the like technology to explain Kang's
blue appearance from the comics like
they keep Jonathan Majors looking like
himself just as he did Loki as we said
at the beginning we don't want to put
anything on that face if we can help it
just like let the man let the man act
right I mean like but in the comics the
his blue face was because of the suit as
well so like that's right that's right
it was blue it's just you you rarely
ever see him without it it's like
constantly on him uh but like allowing
the actor to just kind of retract it and
and do his act and that's what we like
that's what we want and smt said that's
clueless that's truest to the comics
um but and I think you know as we all
went to the Loki finale we're like well
is he gonna be blue and they kind of did
a similar face with Jonathan Majors when
those elevator doors first opened he
walked into some blue lights and they
were able to play both sides of it I
think um but one thing we should note
from this quantumania trailers we do see
Kang's face three times in the trailer
the uh one is really easy to see if you
watch the IMAX version of the trailer
it's at one minute 36 seconds and to me
this is the most important angle we see
of him because you can actually see
Kang's face is in a different light and
it looks blue like that helmet is on but
as he lowers into frame you can see the
curves of Jonathan major's face his
cheek his nose if he had a face shield
cover like he does in the other shot
where he's wearing it I don't know if it
would be that thin or at least thin
enough to match the guardian you know
the Guardians of the Galaxy one is kind
of a bubbly layer over you it's not like
perfectly contoured to your silhouette
uh this is perfectly contoured with
silhouette so it's probably not the same
exact technology or it this might just
be a different gang with like a
different kind of suit
um maybe we're thinking it maybe it's
just like unfinished VFX I don't know
okay personally I just think quantumania
is too soon for multiple kangs in a
single movie
um not to say they won't do it they're
just gonna have to make some interesting
choices to make it different from the
other times we've seen multiple variants
on screen the same time currently in the
MCU we're going to see a lot more of
that we've already seen multiple Peters
multiple Loki's multiple doctor Stranges
in a scene together uh we're probably
going to see multiple Reed Richards in a
scene together so to make Kang distinct
my thought is maybe do one at a time in
each TV show or movie and let Jonathan
Majors completely take over that story
but I think just for the sake of the
argument here let's let's like explore
this thought experiment for what reason
might there be multiple kings in the
quantum realm could this be another void
scenario where multiple kangs have been
banished into Exile and they all kind of
have rivalries could every pythian foot
soldier that we see in Kang's Fleet in
his army could each of them be a Kang
variant and there's some kind of crazy
hierarchy among kangs that we don't know
about I I definitely think that there is
a possibility for multiple Kings to be
in the quantum realm because of what we
we learned from um he who remains in the
Loki finale I mean he's just like we
learned that the TVA exists to keep
Kings from coming up and I think that at
the Quan Quantum level
um there could be like some remnants of
that King War trapped in the quantum
realm and unable to escape and enter the
timeline
um and he kept them there because like
that's their prison he's like you know
what I'm not gonna kill you you just I
want someone to know that I won because
if no one knows that I won then like
what's the point
um so yeah so he keeps them there and
like he traps them there I think a huge
part of Kang's goal could be like
escaping the quantum realm and like
getting that technology to grow and to
be human-sized into actually conquer
um I think that like maybe that's what
he wants God to get he's like hey maybe
like I just I just don't know I don't
have that technology that you have to to
get big so like please get me the get
big sauce I need to get big sauce for my
machine I like that I was thinking I I
like the ending
um more so and that's what I also
originally thought and still think is
that he just needs the pieces to get out
of there but I do I like the idea of if
the TVA was this like situation to be
like we're protecting you from different
variations of myself one of the
dimensions was the quantum realm sending
this one there and specifically this one
because this one can't get out it's
really hard for this one to get out so I
want to believe that there's only one
there because I don't think a million
Kings could be in there and not fight
for power if that makes sense
um I feel like it would just be turmoil
and from what we've seen in the trailer
it doesn't look like it's too much of
like
it could be like different uh uh is it
fat factions it could it could be
something similar to that but like the
scene where we see Bill Murray I'm like
yeah this Utopia doesn't look too
disorganized so I think there is just
only one cane because three kings at all
could probably tear that place up so
that's my yeah yeah I think that makes
the most sense I I as I was like kind of
following this thought train long off
the cliff I've been thinking a lot about
uh trying to reconcile the differences
between the quantum realm and wherever
the TBA is so the TBA in the comics is
in the null time zone we don't know if
the TVA in um the MCU is in the null
time zone but one thing we know about
the TVA from Loki is that time basically
stands still there we have uh the the
void the headquarters of the TVA we have
wherever the Citadel is they're all part
of this Timeless uh realm like uh no one
ages in the void uh none of the Chrono
monitors age they all just kind of stay
frozen in time the key difference
between that and the quantum realm is
people still age in the quantum realm uh
Michelle Pfeiffer aged for the decade
she was there Scott Lang did not because
he went into a separate time Vortex
that's a separate thing from the normal
Quantum realm whereas if Scott just
stayed there in the quantum room for
five years he would have aged for five
years he just floated into a Vortex so
um so I think that might that might tell
us a lot like maybe he remains
constructed the the void in a specific
way so that when he banishes things
there they um they continue to just stay
frozen in time no problem but you can't
put a Kang down in the void because if
they have time then they can like use
that uh they can uh if they could just
stay there forever and ever and ever
then eventually they're going to find a
way to break out of it so he needs to
put them in a place that is separate
from the rest of the world uh a place
without like the kind of technology that
you can use to like build time travel or
Multiverse technology but you'll you're
eventually going to age in the quantum
realm so if you send kangs down there
they're gonna grow older they're gonna
get 80 90 100 120 years old and
eventually they're going to die of old
age their bodies are going to give out
so maybe that's why the quantum realm is
built the way it is maybe that was a
specific prison like a solitary
confinement section of a prison uh to
send Kang variants to uh that's like
where Elias sent them after he devoured
them I don't know maybe that's really
fun I like the idea that what's a prison
to Kings is like an entire world to
others they're like oh yeah this is a
great place or well we don't know if
it's a great place but I bet people are
like this is like a nation of people and
then gang's like this is a prison
this is awful right and I hate it here
sort of like uh well in a different way
but like agent Smith in The Matrix he's
like I hate being here it's all these
people are disgusting I'm trying to get
out of here
I need to be free and you are the key
I did that monologue for a freshman year
drama class thinking that no one would
know what it was from and everyone
afterwards they're like yeah that's from
The Matrix like why don't you pick a
play
it is a play
it is a place
it started off as a Broadway musical and
then they adapted it all right we have
uh some more uh things we want to
discuss when it comes to the
relationship between quantumania Kang
and what we're gonna see in the site in
the Loki side of the Multiverse first we
want to thank Helix sleep for sponsoring
this episode whether you spend your
nights in our universe or in the quantum
realm One Thing Remains true sleep is
important here at new rockstars We Trust
Helix to protect our sleep with the best
mattresses in the world I have a helix
mattress Mt uh recently producer Zach
and producer John got Helix mattresses
Helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type and your sleep preferences to
the perfect matches for you everybody's
unique Helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
burn mattresses matches is great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
matches are great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains even
a helix plus mattress of plus size
sleepers Mt has the Helix mattress how
do you sleep Mt I sleep like a baby man
I sleep like I am a rock and it's all
thanks to my Helix mattress thank you
Helix I love you so just go to
helixsleep.com inside Marvel take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
a trade out for 100 nights risk-free
Helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at Helix sleep.com Marvel
we also want to thank Roan for
sponsoring this episode it can be
stressful finding the changing clothes
for different activities throughout the
day that's why you should check out
Rhone the dress shirt was due for a
radical reinvention and brown stepped up
to the challenge Rowan's commuter shirt
is the most comfortable breathable and
flexible shirt known to man ruin's
comfortable four-way stretch fabric
provides breathability and flexibility
it leaves you free to enjoy what life
throws your wave from your work time to
your free time with rhone's wrinkle
release technology wrinkles disappear as
you stretch and wear the shirt it's that
easy Roan utilizes gold Fusion anti-odor
technology to keep you smelling fresh
and clean all day long more importantly
Roan is 100 machine washable so you can
ditch to dry cleaner altogether producer
Brandon loves his commuter shirt because
he can go from work straight to the
theater to catch the show without having
to change shirts in between the commuter
shirt can get you through any work day
and straight into whatever comes next
head to rhone.com Marvel news promo code
Marvel to save 20 off your entire order
that's 20 off your entire order when you
go to r h o n e.com slash Marvel and use
the code Marvel it's time to find your
corner office Comfort okay I think a
question we should ask is is the
quantumania Kang the same Kang as the
Loki season two gang the giant statue
Kang that we see at the end of Loki
season one are these different gangs are
they the same gang what do you what do
you think I think they got to be
different right is even based off of
like looks because the outfit was
different
I need to go back in let me look let me
let me also Google this the Loki statue
because I I need to see it again
let's see that it does look it looks
very similar to um the suit that he has
in the trailer I think
um because like that's the that's the
Kang suit oh it is the Kings too comic
book Acura King I think it is it would
have to mean that uh Loki in quantumania
is like Victorious at the end of this
movie to set him up to a rule over the
TVA in season two of Loki right yeah
I think you said Loki I did say the low
key to be victorious I meant the king to
be victorious coming out of quantumania
to set him up to rule over the TVA not
to be that person that's like I have the
image in front of me
but the okay so the Kang statue does
resemble the king from quantumania but
it doesn't resemble
it doesn't resemble the original the
first king we saw and I know the first
king we saw was the like domino effect
to the other kings being released but
I'm like right do you think there's just
some kings that dress this
yeah they show up to the party and
they're like yeah God damn it they're
doing that Tick Tock turn where their
girlfriends buy them the same outfit and
they show up and they're wearing the
same outfit I honestly do think like
there are multiple kings that do dress
the exact same because like we see that
in the comics there are multiple kings
that look blue and have that same suit
um and have completely different types
of lives so like there was a possibility
that like they're they complete they
could be completely different Kings here
yeah this one also the statue one
technically doesn't have the scar
technically yeah I I would understand
also being like if you're gonna make a
statue of me make sure my brothers are
taken out take out my straw take out the
scars no scars leave the stretch marks
but take off the scarf
I want them to know I'm thick when I die
now when you when you
When you crush give me a nice
nice
none of that statue of David [ __ ] that
that real thing the real thing
so there's not enough Stone
we'll get the stove
I'm disgusted
do you think uh when they carved like
Thomas Jefferson or Abraham Lincoln for
Washington do you see the do you see
their ghosts were just hanging out in
there like
oh
look at me please look at me
you're supposed to be honest Abe he's
like
I am I am
um I I yeah I I don't think okay maybe I
don't think it is maybe I don't think it
is
but it makes sense see I I think like we
need uh to number our tanks we need to
do it like the Michael Scott effect of
just like getting a marker and marking
their arms you know like I think we need
to number them or give them nicknames
you know like uh we have with strange we
kind of Defender strange we had uh a38
strange like we can call them King prime
or Alpha Kang and then just kind of work
your way down the Greek letters or
something like that like I wonder if
like the one who Lords over the TBA is
that gonna be king crime are we not
gonna make Kang Prime till Kang Dynasty
you think probably that makes sense it's
called keg Dynasty that's like the
ultimate King right the best yeah we've
got to meet King Prime in the in the
King Dynasty though like I think there
was a chance that like this TVA at the
end of Loki could be what this King that
we're seeing in quantumania what he lost
and like what he's trying to reclaim
because like I think that this is a
completely separate TVA ruling over a
completely separate Multiverse whether
it's the fox Multiverse or whatever
Marvel Multiverse it is whatever
um and I think that there was a
possibility here that this King that
we're seeing in Ant-Man was like I got
that [ __ ] uh taken away from me and I
want it back and so like I just need you
your help to to get what I want to get
that TVA back and maybe like the TVA
being ruled um at the end of Loki is
secretly being run by rensslayer um
because we see her leave and
um so I don't know do we I know that we
don't know what time time is in
um in Loki but do we know if
Loki the series is coming out after uh
quantumania yeah I think Loki is coming
summer 2023. so it could be that subtle
little thing that he he addresses a
little bit in quantumania of like I was
dethroned and I need to go back to my
TVA and then that's where we can pick up
where mt's pitch is with Ren Slayer
being in charge of the TVA it just seems
like someone that has a statue in the
TVA would have more pull on where they
go in our scent and like done you know
because it's like if Rensselaer takes
over great I would love that but I'm
also like this man had a statue it seems
like a lot of people kind of worked for
him and you guys just kicked him out
I think we're going to meet a finite
number of kanks I think that's the way
you do it right when you're trying to
establish there's like you know there's
seven evil ex-boyfriends there's seven
horcruxes we gotta find like to give
ourselves a finite number like he who
remains was the Exile he didn't even go
by Kang at that point he was like uh the
weird Guardian before you go into the
Cave of Wonders or whatever like you
don't want to go down this path here
trouble lies ahead so like he's kind of
the mythological like uh weirdo the kind
of troll uh before the bridge
um on the other side of the bridge
there's like seven obstacles right it's
I would imagine like name seven Kings
like the number seven is kind of the the
largest uh single digit prime number
right is that is that correct yeah uh so
that's probably why seven has some kind
of significance that we see throughout
mythology and religion and fiction and
everything
um uh all three
thing but anywho I think the um uh that
like num name seven kangs and then the
first Kang we meet is in quantumania the
second Kang we meet is in Loki season
two and that leaves like a certain
number of kangs left that they have to
foil in in the movie duration of uh of
Kang Dynasty but maybe there's like an
an alpha king a king Prime like there
could be four in Kang Dynasty leaving
one left over who's like yes I've got
two all together you're in battle world
now [ __ ] fight each other
Secret Wars and that's how we end phase
six uh that's my thinking bro just give
yourself a limited number I am really
hoping that um I forget his name the
dude from uh the good place that was
just uh confirmed to be in quantumania
oh Williams oh yeah William Jackson
Harper yes I am secretly hoping that he
is a king variant uh the king very Mr
Griffin who owns uh King Tower in the in
the Marvel Comics I would love for him
to play Mr Griffin in some type of Young
Avengers project I just wanted to became
variants so bad as soon as he got casted
everyone was like putting their theories
and I was like I hope he's just a cake
there yet that looks different than
brother than John the majors I would
love just I I want them to get to
variations where they don't look like
him like how the Loki's didn't look like
Tom Hiddleston so I'm like yeah I want
to see that there is ones that just
don't look like him I kind of want to
see Keenan Thompson as a kid
and Kang is uh has been on SNL for like
23 years and he's just been running SNL
he's just running SNL he got his own
show now that's and that's his he's like
want to take over SNL I want to be
honestly okay
yo let's get
a cane going on I would love the idea
that King it was like in this universe
he was like yeah I can't wait to do
what's up with that and then Black
Jeopardy for like five years yes
[Music]
yeah yeah I want like this is something
that bugs me is like casting directors
in Hollywood seem to place this barrier
between TV and film and certain actors
are allowed to be on film some actors
are only allowed to be in TV like who's
the guy from the good place who plays uh
Nick in good places they're forgetting
everyone's name from the good place
right
or not the good place I meant to say um
uh a new girl Jake Johnson so oh my God
the so perfect example Jake Johnson is
allowed to be in TV he's not allowed to
be in movies they made it a new version
of Jake Johnson named Oscar Isaac who
gets to be in movies they're the same
person they have the same delivery
John I think Oscar Isaac I think Oscar
Isaac and Jake Johnson look exactly like
mine no no no no no they are the same
human being of the right person
let me look uh Jake Johnson kind of they
look exactly the same and they have the
same comedic they have the same kinetics
comedic speed but Jake Johnson I
guarantee he wakes up every day saying
[ __ ] you Oscar Isaac because I can't be
in movies because but hey you Spider-Man
so it's fine they both get to voice
characters and Spider-Man one plays
Miguel O'Hara one plays uh right so but
he can voice characters but he's not
allowed to be in movies like that you
see now Marvel TV has been the Saving
Grace for lot of these because uh
casting director's like all right we can
put TV actors in these things so you get
like Catherine Han who gets to be with
movie stars like uh like Elizabeth Olsen
and Paul Bettany I don't know what the
science is I think they have weird
little compasses where they measure
people's facial uh proportions they're
like yes this can be projected in IMAX
so we're allowed to put their face but
if you put like Tom Cruise in a TV show
everyone's like Ugh his face is
sandwiched and his teeth are misaligned
like I think there's like a Weird
Science that tells Castle director so
they can't put TV actors on big screens
for whatever reason yep speaking of Jake
Johnson in quantumania I kind of hope
he's in Quantum I mean he's not
confirmed for that at all but I kind of
hope he's secretly in it as um the
irredeemable Ant-Man
um Eric O'Grady I feel like Jake Johnson
would be so good of just like a really
irresponsible Ant-Man he's just like you
know what I'm just using it to just you
know do do whatever I want you know it's
just really really fun
um so that'd be really cool I don't know
It's the weird band casting Mt fan
casting over here empty Fan cast my
favorite segment I'm just kind of like
spitballing for a second here which I do
all the time especially late in these
episodes of inside Marvel but I think I
think
these uh the MCU on Disney Plus benefits
from having more TV actors because the
difference between film actors film
actors are like I want to know my
characters beats the full Arc I want to
know where my character is going and how
his story will end so you bring in these
film actors and then they're like
they're playing more subtle they're
thinking about the big picture of the
character whereas then you get Catherine
Hahn in here and she's a TV actor she
can do whatever she's like I'm just
gonna make the most of this moment and
create a moment for the DP so that they
can like shoot the shot and then the
editor's like yeah sure great like I
think TV actors are better at like
finding their Mark hitting their Mark
delivering something with a clean clear
uh take that seems a little wacky and it
isn't necessarily consistent with like
the full Arc of a character but who the
f cares in the MCU everything's like a
TV episode because like it's just
setting up the next thing it's all about
the Cliffhanger I think that's what a
lot of people well not a lot of people
but some people gripe about the MCU is
that like it doesn't have this kind of
like clear Direction it's just kind of
going play by play it's more tactics
less strategy but I don't know I'm
enjoying the ride I don't care I think
it's just a this is my argument to get
more TV actors on screen and less of
these beautiful model weird box face
High cheekbone film actors yes bro I'm
telling you this we should get Schmidt
from New Girl to play
um Bob the Hydra agent in Deadpool 3. I
think that he would make a great Bob
um it'd be really fun either Schmidt or
um what's his face the dude from Always
Sunny uh Mac Charlie
um is like good friends with Ryan
Reynolds I think you'd also make a good
Bob from Hydra who was Deadpool's friend
in the comics so I think it could be
really fun could you imagine those two
together for the next three years
and then you throw in Hugh Jackman Jesus
Christ who has been better for the MCU
Christian Bale or Catherine Hahn just
ask yourself that question Christian
bill you ask a nominated actor he's an
amazing actor did he do anything for the
MCU and score of the god butchered no
but Catherine Hahn I want to see her in
a million more things I do too okay
he's a crazy person he's a Looney Tune
coven of chaos make it even worse they
just got Eric Andre and Sushi zamada who
are genuinely good actors when they're
not playing the craziest people on TV
and I'm like you guys just keep getting
comedic TV people and they're very good
and I can't wait until this is the best
thing that comes they're serviceable the
cover of chaos is probably gonna be
surprisingly funny
uh a coven of witches with sashir zamada
and Aubry Plaza seems so fun it's like
an amazing show such an SNL such an SNL
episode Keenan Keenan
yes I'm so excited
oh my God where's the Keenan robot we
have a canva robot we need a keynote
robot for SNL we'll leave it there for
this episode of inside Marvel Now if you
haven't already be sure to watch
Jessica's spoiler-free review of black
panther what kind of forever she had
such uh an amazing take on this film and
I highly recommend you watch it it's now
up on the channel mt's explanation to
the post-credits scene will be up on the
channel tomorrow and then my uh in-depth
Easter egg breakdown will be up on the
channel on Saturday and the three of us
are going to spend a lot more time
talking about this film on next week's
episode so stay tuned for that you can
follow me at follow Jessica at Lulu
underscored Clemens follow Mt at Mass
retainment subscribe to inside Marvel
wherever here podcast subscribe to new
rockstars thank you so much for watching
and we'll see you next week bye
everybody
foreign